you shared yesterday on twitter a graph
of leonardo dicaprio's age and his
girlfriend's ages it went viral on the
dater's beautiful subreddit can you
explain what that graph shows please
yeah so hopefully you'll be able to put
it on the screen but it basically shows
like as leonardo's age goes up linearly
uh the age of his mates stays roughly
the same at about 25 it was down at
around 18 19 when he's a little bit
younger but it seems to be uh 25 that
it's his cutoff point for the last maybe
nine or ten girlfriends it's been a
consistent pack reached 25 and then he
replaces them with another one yeah and
it's what it sparked some wild discourse
you know online and it's revealed a lot
of kind of intrasexual competition and
stuff like that so you have some women
talking about oh saying oh he's such a
creep you know he's old enough to be
their father which i think is
interesting whenever um women or people
criticize a big age-gap relationship
what they do is they leverage our incest
disgust by saying things like he's old
enough to be her father and you know
it's not related there's no genetic link
at all it's not disgusting on that level
but they leverage that our intuitive
feeling of incest disgust um but and
another comment i saw on this um
leo age gap thing is oh it's such a sign
that he's immature and not able to
attract women his own age and any guy
who does that is such a creep and that's
just so purely intrasexual competition
like of course women over the age of 30
would still be interested in leonardo
dicaprio like that is no mystery it's
not exactly horrible for these women to
be dating
handsome mega millionaire
movie star leonardo dicaprio it's not
hell right and another interesting take
i saw on it which was a weird twist um
is someone said i think it's actually
kind of nice that he knows he can't go
beyond 25 with a woman and he's always
but at least he's not taking away her
fertile years she still has chance to
recover it it would be worse if he
pushed it all the way to 30 and then
just
cut and left which you can kind of say i
don't know how intentional that is that
might be a charitable interpretation of
yes leon's behavior but um but yeah but
it's a like i put it up
put up the graph and said oh if only we
had a grand meta theory of human
psychology and human nature to explain
leonardo dicaprio's preference for
beautiful fertile young women you know
with the
yeah people people getting very very
excited about this craft
the interesting thing is i didn't see
any of the girls talk about this online
but
it has to be a signal in the same way as
one of the best ways to be attractive as
a man is to walk into the club with a
couple of girls on your arm that are
both attractive and seem to give you
attention
it has to be the case
that somewhere deep in the programming
of some women they look at the fact that
leo is able to date a woman that's half
his age and think
he's getting something right there
now this is not the sort of thing that
would be very
popular to post about online the fact
that you use the mate value of a man
as a proxy for the man's mate value
himself especially as he gets older
which is something that is like
completely um
irreversible right there's no there's
nothing you can do about that you can't
you can't lift your way out of being 53.
yeah absolutely and like they've done a
lot of studies that show that mate value
or your sense of your own mate value is
a direct proxy for self-esteem
particularly for men so
yeah i wouldn't be surprised that and a
lot of women in their mate preferences
engage in mate copying so make made
choice copying so if one woman kind of
it's like fashion almost if one woman
endorses a guy he suddenly becomes oh
well he must be uh he must be all right
someone vetted him you know the example
i use there is what's his name phil
davison or pete davison yes he's
suddenly able to pull every smoking hot
woman in hollywood like all of a sudden
and it snowballs and you might even
notice chris in your own life that
sometimes when you have a girlfriend you
seem to get a bit more attention and i
don't know from other women and i don't
know whether it's because you're more
relaxed and your guard is a bit more
down but some of it might be
oh yeah someone has considered him high
value enough but so the commentator who
put up about leo she actually made the
opposite argument and she said oh i find
it so hot when a man is dating an older
woman who is um like very sophisticated
because it signals he's obviously smart
whereas if he goes for the fertile young
woman it signals that he's
he's not able to keep up with the
intellectual yeah
i've got the tweet i've got the tweet
here the whole dicaprio thing reminds me
one reason a guy might constantly choose
much younger partners is because women
his own age have higher standards from
an adult woman's point of view when we
see a man with a woman more or less his
age or older we know that guy is most
likely great macron is probably the most
extreme we know of every time i look at
that guy i'm thinking oh my god he must
be [ __ ] smart if that woman who could
have picked from a 40-year age range
thinks that he's the partner
that could not be more backwards that
literally could not be more backward how
are you going to try and tell me that a
woman that's 53
is
higher he's going to have higher
standards than a woman that is slap bang
in the middle of her fertile years yeah
yeah there's a little bit wrong and i
did retweet it to try and maybe spark a
bit of debate and
the woman who wrote the tweet anna gatt
i actually really admire her most of her
twitter uh content and she runs a really
cool
organization called the inter intellect
which puts on kind of intellectual
gather salon type gatherings so i don't
mean to like dunk on her take and it is
interesting on one level and maybe there
is some truth to it but yeah it's
missing that piece of
you know i feel like maybe saying to her
your intrasexual competition is showing
but but you know intrasexual competition
particularly for women is very hidden
even to themselves yeah so the you can't
let it show you can't really it has to
be all uh subtle um
which is interesting so you might not
even actually perceive a lesson um yeah
i think that the
the
younger women versus older women thing
is it's a difficult area to get into
right like
especially with the world of red pill at
the moment
age is one of those things that gets
weaponized by the guys that are talking
in that red pill space and never gets
used as a tactic that men should take on
in order to open up their dating
opportunities which just blows my mind
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]